En los últimos años Granja Arce
ha cosechado alrededor de
1000 manzanas
más que su principal rival de la región,
Huerto Río Grande.
Debido al clima frío de este año,
la cosecha bajó en cantidad por 1/3.
Sin embargo
ambas granjas compensaron parte de este déficit mediante la compra de cantidades iguales de manzanas
de las granjas de estados vecinos.
¿Qué se puede decir del número
de manzanas en cada granja?
¿Y tiene una granja mayor cantidad
de manzanas que la otra
o tienen la misma cantidad?
¿Y cómo lo sabes?
Muy bien entonces,
vamos a resolver esto, vamos a...
vamos a primero definir algunas variables
entonces,
voy a definir estas variables
sea "m"
igual al número de manzanas...
el número de manzanas
en Granja Arce,
y
esto es en Granja Arce
y ahora sea "r" igual
al número de manzanas de Huerto Río Grande,
así que "r"
es igual al número de manzanas de
Huerto Río Grande
y vamos a,
voy a leer otra vez este primer párrafo
dice, "En los últimos años
Granja Arce ha cosechado alrededor de
1000 manzanas más
que su principal rival de la región,
Huerto Río Grande",
y ok,
entonces podemos decir que "m"
es aproximadamente igual,
a "r" más 1000
ajá, o como, como no sabemos la cantidad exacta
porque aquí dice alrededor de 1000,
entonces podemos decir que,
en un año normal Granje Arce
denotado por "m",
tiene una mayor cantidad de manzanas
que "Río Grande"
denotado por "r",
entonces,
"m" es mayor que "r"
y esto sucede en un año normal entonces
por aproximadamente 1000 manzanas más
"m" es mayor que "r" en un año normal.
Ahora aquí dice que,
que
debido al frío
bajaron la cantidad por 1/3 ambos,
así que
"m" es mayor que "r" en un año normal,
pero este año...
este año "m" y "r"
bajaron por 1/3,
así que es lo mismo que decir,
que ahora tenemos
2/3 de la cantidad
y voy a poner aquí un ejemplo
para que se entienda un poco más.
Digamos que yo tengo "x"
y le restó 1/3x,
así que me quedan
2/3x
y ese es el ejemplo
ahora muy bien,
bajaron por 1/3 la...
la cantidad,
es lo mismo que tener 2/3,
si yo multiplico
esta desigualdad 2/3,
la desigualdad se mantiene por que estoy multiplicando por un número que es positivo,
y estoy multiplicando
ambos lados de la desigualdad entonces,
es como que tuvieras una balanza,
se queda igual,
si yo multiplicara por un número negativo
entonces si cambiaría la desigualdad,
se voltearía
pero estoy multiplicando por 2/3,
2/3m es mayor que 2/3r
y lo que puedo hacer
es dibujar aquí una recta numérica,
tal vez esto parezca un poco intuitivo,
si así lo es disculpa,
pero si no bueno,
no hace daño aprender,
así que bueno, en fin,
digamos que aquí está,
por aquí ha de estar
"m", "m" tiene
1000 manzanas más que Río Grande
en un año normal
y Río Grande está por aquí,
ahora si le quitamos
2/3 a "m",
entonces estaremos más o menos,
más o menos por aquí, digamos
esto es,
esto sería 2/3m,
2/3m, ahora,
2/3r
¿eso dónde estaría?
eso está más o menos...
2/3r estaría más o menos por aquí,
no es exacto pero, supongamos...
entonces puedes ver que 2/3r,
sigue siendo menor que 2/3m,
así bueno,
se mantiene la desigualdad como puedes ver.
2/3m es mayor que 2/3r
y ahora seguimos leyendo dice,
"Sin embargo ambas granjas compensaron
parte de este déficit mediante la compra
de cantidades iguales de manzanas
de las granjas de estados vecinos."
Así que ok,
sea "a"
igual a la cantidad de manzanas...
igual a la cantidad de manzanas
que ambos compraron
ajá, entonces,  ok
ambos compraron la misma cantidad de manzanas, podemos...
podemos sumar "a"
a ambos lados de la desigualdad,
y no va a cambiar la desigualdad, se va a mantener,
siempre y cuando tú
sumes o restes la misma cantidad
a ambos lados de una desigualdad,
la desigualdad se mantiene,
entonces sumamos "a" a 2/3m,
es mayor que 2/3r más "a"
esta es la cantidad
de manzanas que tiene
Granja Arce
después de comprar manzanas,
y es la cantidad de manzanas
que tiene Río Grande
así que, puedes verlo aquí, Granja Arce sigue teniendo más manzanas que Río Grande
en un año normal,
y ahora este año tiene
2/3 de la producción
pero luego compró una cantidad
"a" de manzanas, entonces,
por poner un ejemplo digamos que
digamos que "a" es esta cantidad,
esta cantidad entonces,
digamos por ejemplo que...
que Granja Arce,
llega a "m" otra vez, ajá,
y ahora, si Río Grande
también compró la misma cantidad "a" de manzanas,
2/3r más "a",
sería esto
llegaríamos aquí.
Lo voy a hacer un poco diferente,
digamos que no quiero que
que se solapen,
pero digamos
que Granja Arce compra
"a" cantidad de manzanas,
entonces,
esto es "a"
esto es "a" voy ahora a copiar,
para que sea la misma cantidad "a"
y Río Grande también compra
la misma cantidad de manzanas "a"
y entonces simplemente
copio esto y lo pego
así que ya tenemos el resultado.
Tenemos que ésta,
así que esto voy a poner aquí una línea,
que corresponde a la cantidad de manzanas
que tiene Río Grande,
esta es la cantidad de manzanas
que tiene el Río Grande
esto es igual,
esto es 2/3r más "a",
lo voy a poner aquí
2/3r más "a"
corresponde a Río Grande
y a Granja Arce.
Granja Arce
tiene 2/3m mas "a"
por lo tanto,
puedes ver que Granja Arce
sigue teniendo
más manzanas que Río Grande.